[Music]
well first of all thank you so much for
giving us season three it's absolutely
amazing uh i have to say i've seen it
but for the folks who haven't yet the
trailer let's just say previews that
barry's having a rough go of it and
really having a hard time balancing so
what was it like jumping into the chaos
of where we left him in season two for
season three you know it's a different
kind of it's a tough season you know it
was a tough tough thing to kind of
figure her out um
but you know he he's definitely uh
i don't know his back is against the
wall this season
i don't know how else to say it
you know he's really
i you don't think things could get worse
but they do and it's kind of his you
know it's his fault so
yeah i heard you say in an interview
it's going to be interesting to see if
fans are going to be able to stick with
barry as he goes through this season
and i know it's sort of like around the
season theme is this idea of like if
what you do
is also the thing that destroys you is
what the thing that you're good at i
know like you can't climb up your own
stuff for that i i do have to say like
what do you think themes are going to
play out on that and how therapeutic was
it to kind of like write that through a
season of television yeah i mean i never
try to
the yeah doing this stuff is never a
therapy for me in any way hopefully
people don't watch the show especially
some of the scenes and think oh he's
working something out because they'll be
like oh he's a monster
um
it's you know definitely these themes of
redemption and and can you you know
forgiveness is something that has to be
earned
and then is that even
is forgiveness even a thing you know and
i don't really know the answer to these
things and that's that's why it's fun to
create stuff because you can kind of ask
yourself these questions and
try to
figure it out but this season
he's definitely
it's he's definitely in a darker place
than he has been the first two seasons
and that's really saying something so i
don't i don't know if uh
yeah we might be scared it's still a
comedy right it's still funny yeah i
actually feel like to see this season
has some of the funniest stuff we've
ever done it gets really silly in some
parts but yeah it is a it is it's rough
okay well i hope somebody that's
bringing
maybe a little bit of light to it i
can't think of anything less from him
henry winkler but you know i think he
said that barry's going into the season
knowing that
gene likely saved his life and just that
dynamic between the two talk about you
know
you and henry working that out and what
you wanted their relationship to be in
season three
well their relationships are very
complicated because barry kind of sees
him as yeah the guy that
saved his life and and all these things
and then uh
and then the end of season two from
barry's point of view is that you know
cousino
uh saw janus's you know uh body and all
this stuff and barry's
you know uh they were both arrested and
it was you know and all this stuff and
it was terrible and you know he kind of
goes away uh
kind of
into
hiding in a way barry does you know kind
of emotionally and
and and
and cousnow unbeknownst to barry uh
knows
where we pick up and so
it was kind of going like what we like
to do every season we like to write
ourselves into a corner and go
well let's see what happens
yeah and i've heard you've already
written yourself into a corner for
season four but you've already mapped it
out are you still committed to ten
episodes directing and are you crazy
oh yeah yeah i'm crazy
[Music]
can you handle more amazing news
i just have to ask you now that gene
knows what barry did and then also with
your dynamic with the actual bill hater
in the sense that he's already written
out so much
ahead of time
how long before you find out the big
twists and turns and is it sort of the
same way that you're approaching gene
this year with him knowing but maybe not
wanting to let everyone know that he
knows do you know what i think that in
the beginning gene knows that it sinks
in you know he just learned to love
somebody right he really didn't love
anybody before uh janice
before paula
and
then to have
like all right i so i'm letting i'm
letting this woman into my life i'm
opening my life now she's gone
now i know who
made her gone now i'm so angry i i can't
even taste food now i've got revenge how
do i even do that the thing that about
this season is so much about people's
past coming to haunt them and also about
revenge what is it like for you maybe
with the gene you know the
personification of the long-term
character actor really embracing his
villainous side of it this year or his
darker side well first of all he's fun
to play
second of all
you know um in the in the second season
i had a meeting with alec
berg and bill and i said guys i am not
complaining
i am grateful
i love doing this show
but the character you wrote in season
two
i don't see
any
like
nod to the guy in season one
you know this guy has a different name i
played gene in season one this guy could
be bob
yeah yeah then
they said
i hear you it is important that you take
care of your character
we can make some
kind of correct you know um
accommodation but this is where we're
going because we don't want to repeat
ourselves
like so many sitcoms do with
the same you know the same same same now
season three
i asked no questions
i got my ticket i got on the train i
found my seat
oh oh well then i have to ask you
on the seat is are we looking out on
darkness are we looking out on sunshine
i went on to amazon and i got myself a
ma
a minus hat
with a lamp on top
wow yeah
wow that's what everyone is saying bill
everyone's like trying to get us like
mentally and physically prepared which i
think they should since they made us
wait so long i think it's the beauty in
the sense that i think you guys did your
first table read and then you got shut
down and
it was amazing it was amazing how about
this we did our first table read not
knowing the danger
that was lurking yeah and we all had
lunch and you know finger food and we're
oh there's a salami and a piece of
cheese with a cracker i think i'll take
that or you're going to have some too go
right ahead and then the next day we
came in to read and they said you know
i think you have to go home
two weeks
just go home two weeks
two and a half years later
yeah no that's exactly right well i have
to ask you one of the you know problems
with covet is like we lost that together
time and i know one of the cool
situations that your filming schedule
provided for you and bill is that you
guys actually did like coffee chats like
early in the morning like y'all would
maybe have like breakfast before you
guys went on set oh my god yeah i was
wondering if you guys have been able to
pick that up again and then like what's
been the the new tenor this is now like
a a longer standing tradition well bill
and i sometimes had lunch together yeah
um in a restaurant he always had salmon
um
because he is the healthiest eater he
has
snacks on set that i wouldn't even
describe to another person
i don't even know what he was eating
but you know he's very healthy he has to
say trim
and uh i of course
am bulging in every area but
um
it was
liberating it was
i don't know
three weeks ago my wife and i flew
across the world and i did a show in
israel and we thought
we're traveling yeah we're we're living
we're
this we're we're checking our luggage
oh my god we're at um masada
you know it was
the same feeling
we weren't just picking up the show
yeah we were starting life again oh wow
i love that i really do i mean i'm glad
you're doing it so many folks love what
gene does what you've done with the
performance i mean it's absolutely
incredible but there's also been talk of
a gene spin-off i have to know your
thoughts on this because the idea of
speaks
right now i would not do a gene i would
not leave
this show
i would not fix something that was not
broken
i love
acting with bill
and with uh
with my other cast members
i love the crew i wouldn't go for all
the tea in china
it would be insane
okay and saying hey i live
because i interact with all these people
and
all of a sudden you know to
the i you know that i was once
confronted with this with uh happy days
they wanted me to do my own show
uh and i said
that's crazy i i am as as as good a
character because
mrs c is my mother
ronnie is my brother that's why chuck
who was the older brother was sent away
because i became the big brother yeah
and now you're going to take me away
from that and i'm gonna have to start
and roll the dice and maybe it'll work
not interesting
i'm so glad you're not i mean i'm just
gonna go ahead and say it like i really
love what you guys are doing with this
let's just let's just say we want to see
those stories but we can keep you there
maybe you can do a voiceover and like
double duty
and do it like
do it do it like however your mother's
style yeah the last thing i was just
going to say is you have to portray
coaching bad acting but also bad actors
world-class actors portraying bad acting
how do you coach
bad acting with the sort of gene hat
it's like a meta sort of situation you
know what what it is is you cannot be
bad
for real
you've got to be great
and then be bad
and create the bad
uh and i tell you one thing i do miss
my acting class
because every one of those people who
are now doing great on their own
were heavy hitters
one is directed and created a show on
netflix one is becoming a director and
is a wonderful actress in killing eve
uh oh you know and on and on and on
i miss them very much i really do
didn't just teach me how to be a better
actor taught me how to be a human being
sarah first of all congratulations on
season three i know folks have been
desperately waiting for it and coming
back to it your character
it the one thing i would say is you
always talk about her tunnel vision and
how she's so obsessed with making it
that she can sort of let things go by
the wayside now that she has her own
show how do you think that's gonna
affect that vision
i think it's a great question yeah sally
has suffered from a kind of myopia since
we met her where the whole world is sort
of um
out of focus and there's just high def
on the one thing that she wants
and she is getting what she wants um and
i think that it's really interesting
what happens to people when they get
what they think they want
um and we go into an exploration of that
a bit of be careful what you wish for
um
it's a tricky biz and uh she she is in a
sort of complicated place of maybe she
thought it was going to be one pure
feeling you know of joy and actually
it's complicated and all the other
things are coming with it she's
overwhelmed the anxiety that comes with
it the visibility that comes with it the
expectation that comes with it
and she's in a vulnerable spot and so
we're sort of playing with how she
navigates that and um yeah and how she
behaves in a place where she's finally
got a little bit of power what does she
do with it
i'm like kind of shuttered to think
about it knowing some of her
darker tendencies but
i mean
i don't know
but that tunnel vision it's also not
just with the work i mean obviously i
think she obviously has that with barry
um do you think that is purposeful or is
that just like is she ever going to put
him in high depth here to your point
that's also a great question i think
that this is a high functioning
relationship in its absolute dysfunction
and they are so bad for each other and
yet it works um because they just see
what they want to see in each other or
they see themselves how they want to be
seen through the projection of the other
um and yeah i think the veneer there is
cracking and um
without giving anything away
i think there's only so long uh a
relationship like that can flourish you
know it has a shelf life
so yeah she does have that myopia and
that dynamic and um
which is lucky because you know he kills
people for a living so if she knew that
2020 vision is not relationship
not for this one
um the other thing about it i mean a lot
of people have pointed it out obviously
this was something that was written for
the character which is also one of the
things that makes her i think
complicated is is her narcissism is just
herself obsession and i think what's
interesting about it is that narcissism
i know made at least in the first season
a lot of people like you know coming
against her more than the guy that
murdered people for a living which i
always thought was so weird
but what is it about it i think in
season two they also showed where that
came from and just the duality of her
narcissism
and just her sort of dashed hopes well i
think that's what we're constantly
trying to do with the show is you're
showing people behave badly and then
we're trying to get underneath the
reasons why they behave that way and for
me i'm endlessly fascinated by that
i think that the the backlash towards
sally in season one was anticipated and
also fascinating mirror to society where
are we at that a woman who's a little
bit narcissistic is much more palatable
than a man who shoots people um and then
we we sort of undercut that in season
two and we understand who she is why she
is the way she is
and you know i've always said oh she's
unlikable let's make her a monster i
want to play a complicated woman who's
making bad choices on a show about
complicated people making bad choices i
was really resistant to becoming the
moral barometer of the show i really
didn't want sally to fall prey to that
just because she's the woman and all of
our writers were very receptive to that
and we fought hard to keep her in a
morally complex place um that that is
correct for the tone of this show and
that is the thesis of the show is like
am i a bad person and what does it mean
to be a bad person and when you have the
opportunity to make the right decision
do you take that choice or do you take
the quick choice that's going to get you
the thing that you want and that's what
we're playing with with all of these
characters and we're pushing mistakes
for all of them and it's endlessly
fascinating to play the other thing too
i think just sort of the theme of the
season and granted we haven't seen
everything but we've seen a little bit
is this idea that
you can be good at something and it
could also be killing you to be good at
something and i'm just curious on those
themes do you have something like that
where you would be like it would be the
death of me to be good at this or do you
have something that you're good at
you're like i never ever want to make
this my job wow that's a great question
i mean being an actor comes with a lot
of um
potential
landmines in that you know it's a
profession that's high low and
i feel lucky that i've been sort of
opposite to sally that i feel like i've
had um
a slow and steady career
where i've i've really got to work with
great people and do things that i love
i think there's a dangerous side to the
level of fame that some people
attain in this business and
i think that it can be very scary thing
and i feel lucky uh not to be in that
category because i think that that would
kill me i think it's very important to
have balance in your life and the
extreme of this profession doesn't lend
itself to that balance
yeah i love doing it so i'm not going to
stop you know
well i do have to say um again i love
your entire body of work but whenever i
watch you in this it makes me question
whether or not you're a nice guy like i
think everyone is just so upset with you
he's getting worse isn't he yes he's
worse
and what he did to barry was so awful
but i guess in his mind it was
retaliation for what barry did to him
and so like where do you think justice
lies with fuchs in regards to barry like
does he like justice lies when barry
does what he says it does what he wants
him to do and i i think unfortunately
that's that's his character arc which is
the it's just
that's it there is no arc there's just
if you don't do what i i want you to do
i'm gonna i'm gonna hurt you and that's
that's what's happening this season
i mean ugh he's so villainous like
what's wonderful i'll tell you what's
what's great though i think is is
because they're using that to tie it
season one and three together
with the way that he's trying to deal
with barry and i think that was
brilliant writing just so cool
yeah the writings the writing on this
show is brilliant they do really seem to
like stretch the bounds of what you can
do on television what you could do in a
dramedy or you know
but the thing is like with your
character do you think he has like a red
line is there anything he's not willing
to do in pursuit of his sort of
domination over barry
i don't think there's anything i think
he's not
emotionally able to
enjoy his own life and that
he's he's at the stopping point now
because all he can do is think about it
so it's a revenge season for this
character
um and i don't think he's emotionally
able to handle more than that
um
and that's bad because his
his friend has ptsd and is getting worse
and is uh going down the rabbit hole
himself so i don't uh i didn't write
season four but i don't see any
reconcile coming oh
that's i mean i didn't see it either
after what he did just the whole way
that everything played out um
there is the scene last year which i
think is so funny which is the little
girl
and sort of like barry y'all sort of
like going through
so everyone's talked to bill and of
course the stunt books about that
episode and what you guys did but let's
talk about you because you were like in
and out of it but also still probably
having to deal with a lot of that
choreography yeah yeah it was a day
where we decided to skip that episode uh
and we shot it last it was just so
so hard to direct that episode
with all the stuff that was going on and
you couldn't use stunt drivers and you
couldn't use stunts
uh when i had to have a car when i had
to drive a car with my feet i had to
drive the car with my feet so
everything was done on the day figure it
out on the day
uh it was a long long couple of days but
so worth it because of the brilliant
performance of that gal she was
unbelievable uh she's the daughter of a
stunt and she's just she was
unbelievable and so good and and bill
deserved an emmy for directing that
episode i thought it's such a i've never
seen fight sequences like that um
just kind of amazing stuff no i think i
i was definitely pulling for that one we
need to make the campaign this year
barry needs like more wins across the
board i see what you're saying like hey
we're we're always happy to be
recognized it's a it's a win to be on
the show that's what we true
um i definitely want to talk about this
because you talk about the writing of
barry and what's crazy about it is like
when we were talking to billy he was
talking about how dark this season gets
and i'm like is it still a company and
he's like yeah no it's like we do some
of the most we're still in ridiculous
situations yeah exactly like it's
hilarious but then it gets really dark
and because of that it just made me
think of shakespearean because even in
the midst of the biggest tragedies that
he wrote there was always these funny
sort of like moments and then there was
dramatic moments within the comments i
just i just did one in macbeth
that was just not to say do you feel
those parallels with barry and that's a
perfect example yeah yeah yeah it was it
was nice for me to be able to do that
just because i'd done so much
uh shakespeare early in my career
in new york and
and around there to so to be able to do
shakespeare on screen was like a nice
circle of your your career so
i was very pleased to do that very lucky
um do you have a do you have a
shakespearean character you feel fuchs
is most like i'm sure there's a few
oh yeah
there's there's
there's probably yago this is close you
know it's so great too because
you and henry sort of
play these sort of different
father s replacement figures and neither
one of them are perfect in that endeavor
oh my goodness no and and you're
very jealous of that that father figure
thing with cousin now i think
another revenge motive
motivation for him as well yeah talk
about how he thinks of gene because that
was literally what i was going to ask
you is like how does he place gene and
and is it more anger towards gene than
it is even to barry i think there is
more anger but more jealousy than anger
i i think
kuzanow kind of took his place after he
decided he wanted to be an actor it's
like what do you mean no we do this and
what do you mean and
hence all the trouble starting from
there so i think he's he's very jealous
of cousin now
and probably was
i
i don't think you can figure out why he
didn't kill him
he could have very easily killed him
um but he did something almost as bad
and he continues this season to do
things
really bad that hook up indices that
hooked up from season one yeah oh wow i
will just ask you this because wow
that's that's really intriguing because
i don't think a lot of people thought
anything you did towards the end like
that was the most unforgivable thing so
the fact that y'all have topped that
makes me very scared for everybody
involved
but it brings me to a great point you
know you bring your shakespeare days for
folks that don't know you've had such a
great and storied
like career as an actor on stage and
screen
and so you've worked with obviously some
incredible directors but what is it like
in this format when you have like this
player coach with bill
what is it what is this directing style
like in comparison to him as a scene
partner and then when he's doing double
duty
uh it's amazing to me that he can switch
hats as quickly as he does as an actor
he he wants to be a director and his
director he wants to be a director
because he'll give himself you know
we'll do a couple you know we'll do
scenes together
and
he'll
turn around on cameras on him and he'll
he'll do it no is that good enough
he wants to get back to the other stuff
he wants to direct and i think that's
great because he's so good at it but
as an actor being directed by him it's
it's wonderful short speak because
he's been through it and it is going
through it as an actor you could say one
can you do the thing where you did the
yeah okay
and
you know you can't do that with a lot of
other
directors who can't communicate that
well i find a lot of younger directors
have
you know i'd like to send an acting 101
just so they can go through that process
a little bit so you can talk to an actor
brings another flavor to it it does and
i and i've worked with you know
really big actors uh who directed and
and it was always a joy because it was
so easy it was so much easier i need a
purpose forgiveness is something that
has to be earned it's like that line in
shawshank redemption get rich or die
trying
first of all congratulations on season
three we got a chance to see some of it
but i'm gonna keep it spoiler free for
the folks haven't seen uh thank you
i mean i i will have to ask you though
you know i think noho hank he gets this
reputation as being like silly but he's
really like a man without a country
because in some ways he's completely
guileless hates all of the violence
that's surrounding him but he's also the
most shrewd person as far as knowing
who's up to no good and whose players
you should be like more mindful of so
what's it like playing those sort of
like two opposing sides of him like at
the same time it's a joy it's a real joy
i mean i um i kind of love playing a
character who's
really just swept up in in the whole uh
in the whole story of it and
and really kind of bless his heart like
doesn't exactly know all of the kind of
ins and outs of everything that's going
on um i i find it to be like a really
kind of refreshing experience to like
as hank be kind of discovering
what's happening and and kind of you
know making these revelations in real
time is is just uh yeah it's just one of
these really really cool things you get
to do as an actor and you know but i do
think that this season in particular is
one in which he's growing and he's
actually beginning to kind of find a bit
more of his footing in terms of who he
is
as
well who he is as a mobster uh and who
he is as you know as a human being what
he needs you know what he needs for the
first time really kind of ever and also
maybe in that like his friendship with
barry is like probably the center of
those conflicting or even if you can
call it a friendship his relationship
with barry is like at the confliction of
all of that um do you think they really
understand each other or do you feel
that like you know no hank understands
very
i think in a weird way
uh i think yeah hank hank really does
get barry i mean i i think it's um
you know he might he might completely
miss the mark sometimes but i think
sometimes it's
you know he
he just he really hits the you know the
nail on the head i mean when barry asks
him you know am i evil you know they're
in there's that scene in the car
together and they're like my evil and
hank is like
i mean
he's
weirdly there for him as a friend like
so much but he gives him the complete
wrong advice he's like yeah oh my god
you're like the most evil person i know
he's trying to lift him up he's trying
to like you know just be the best
possible friend he can be
like is he saying the right thing
absolutely not but like but the
intention is there
that's that dichotomy it's so funny too
and as you've just demonstrated with me
as i was laughing through that because
the minute you mentioned that scene i'm
picturing your voice i'm picturing it
i'm already laughing i've heard this is
sort of your weapon on set that you can
make
doesn't take much as we know from snl to
make bill hater break but apparently you
were like his kryptonite like
his eyes open and like they so talk
about
first of all are you doing it on purpose
[Laughter]
how do you film this stuff because he
says he can't even look at you well i
mean i i don't i don't think i
no the thing is you know if you try this
is the kind of you know
the the real
you know
uh problem with comedy is like if you
try to be funny
you like fall on your face it just
doesn't work that way you literally just
have to be doubled down so committed to
what you're doing
and that's when you know when you lose
yourself in it that's when you actually
just make people
especially bill break uh and um
and yeah and you know that there's like
those times where
i mean he makes me break all the all the
time too i i've you know it's a miracle
that we've actually finished some scenes
because there's just
i i mean
the the crew would just be like guys
please like wrap it up like we gotta get
home
you know but it's just it's just we're
having so much fun yeah i heard it's
almost like a form of hysteria in your
body like you can't at a certain point
once you think something is funny you
can't not think it's funny oh yeah and
and you'll just you have to write it out
you know it's like a medical condition
it's just got to work its way through
your system
and i think the reason why folks are so
fascinated about it is because obviously
we know the show is just written
impeccably and you guys are always
finding new ways to keep the audience
interested but on top of that because
you have so many great comedic voices
like yourself and henry and steven and
obviously bill y'all improvise so much
and i just i'm curious maybe what your
favorite improvised line is because mine
from what i heard of was like poop
mountain or like bs mountain when you
guys were on the road oh yeah yeah
right i'm not sure if i can say it but
yeah yeah suck balls mountains
yes that's it no you could definitely
say it yeah i think honestly i think
that might have been that might have
been like one of my crowding
achievements maybe i i was uh well first
of all i mean shooting that scene was
crazy because it was like a million
degrees up on that roof
and
you know hank goes through a journey
it's like he you know trying to kill
someone almost gets killed himself
vomits out of the sheer just panic of
everything and then proceeds to have
this revelation about you know hiring
barry breaks into dance like there's a
lot going on in that scene but somehow
me and troy the other actor you know we
were just like kind of messing with each
other and and i just
i knew that he would have to kind of say
this thing so i was just like yeah okay
what if i said this and i just kind of
like threw him that one and he being the
great actor that he is you know just
took it and just
ran with it so yeah it's so much fun
week when one of those works oh my god i
love it so much again this is why i see
why y'all can't film anything because
just talking about it is hilarious um
it's and it's it's the character it's no
hank once he like came on screen and
sort of set himself apart from all of
the other sort of mobsters of that world
he was just such a different version of
that that you just can't but love him
and he's become so beloved among the
fans but like what are they telling you
they connect with like is it just that
he's godless is it the fact that you
know he's always going to come with a
nice fit like which he does
that's true that's true he yeah he
always shows up you know in like a
really impeccable way
um but yeah i think we'll you know
that's what's cool is is i mean i get i
get like tons of surprising kind of
compliments and tons of surprising kind
of like thoughts on the character
because some people are just like you
know hank is terrifying you know hank is
like whoa like i would not want to like
cross that dude and then some people are
like i wouldn't like get a beer with
hank like i would have just like i would
just want to like kick it and chill uh
because he just seems like just such a
fun person to be around so it's it's
nice that there's like a character you
know that i get to play that's just such
you know can be interpreted in so many
different ways
you